hi my name is Jesse I'm single and I
love a man who can cook so today three
single guys are going to make me their
perfect lazy Sunday morning breakfast
and I'm going to pick one of them to go
on a date with the plot twist is I
cannot see them and I can only pick the
date based on the dish will I kiss the
cook let's find out
hi i'm matt i love to cook and i hope
today's the day where I finally get my
family to stop asking me if I've met
someone today I'm going to be making my
avocado toast with fried egg and pickled
red onions this for me is my ideal
weekend breakfast it's not that hard to
make it kind of hits all the categories
I like in food it's salty it's Bryan
eats crunchy it's kind of everything all
in one and I love it the first thing I'm
going to do is I'm going to pickle my
red onions and I love red onions because
they have a lot of color and they had a
lot of good vinegary flavor which I like
once that's boiling I just pour it over
my red onions that I have thinly sliced
and I let that sit for about 20 to 30
minutes until I get like a nice color on
it so next I'm going to toast my
sourdough in a cast-iron skillet just a
little bit of olive oil
I like toasting it in a skillet because
I can get the exact color that I want
and also because a lot of slices of
sourdough are actually too big to fit in
a toaster so this kind of works out
perfectly so once my toast is done I get
started on my mashed avocado I just use
one whole avocado add a little bit of
lime juice a little bit of paprika for
some smokiness a little bit of cayenne
just for a hint of spiciness and a tiny
tiny bit of salt and then I mix that all
together until it's nice and smooth and
creamy the final step is the fried egg
and I take my fried eggs super seriously
I like to fry my eggs over medium heat
so I get some oil and I just sprinkle
that in the pan the oil is what really
really helps the outsides crisp a lot
for me the perfect fried egg is nice and
crispy on the outside but has a nice
runny yolk so when you cut into it it
just kind of oozes over whatever you're
eating so to do that I heat a pan over
medium heat and add a little bit of oil
to it crack my egg in there and I watch
and I wait until the outsides get a nice
little golden-brown edge on them at that
point I take a little bit of water and I
just drizzle it in the pan and I
cover it and that's gonna help the
remaining white to set but it's gonna
make sure that the yolk doesn't cook all
the way through now I'm ready to
assemble so I start with my piece of
bread I just generously top it with that
avocado mash I make sure it covers every
inch of the bread
I just put my fried egg right on top and
then I top it all with a little bit of
pickled red onion just to add a nice
little pop of color and there you have
it that's my weekend breakfast right
there this looks perfect to me I've got
my creaminess from the avocados and my
crunch from the onions and it's smooth
and it's spicy hopefully destiny likes
it as much as I do
I'm Andrew I'm a romantic
I can cook what more do you need today
I'm gonna make destiny my ultimate
breakfast sandwich it's an egg and
cheese sandwich on a croissant I like
sandwiches and you can't just have
regular egg so put the two together
next thing we're to do put some olive
oil on it wait till it gets hot we're
gonna throw some peppers some onions I
like mixing my green my red and my
onions a little bit you don't do equal
parts all three you wanna have a little
bit more peppers and onions because
onions have a bit more bite so I'll let
the veggies be the flavor for my food
the reason she's gonna pick my dish over
the other ones is because it's not
trendy it's not gimmicky it's a regular
mature healthy sandwich once again I'm
covering all your bases here what more
do you need as you pour the eggs in over
the veggies you want to make sure that
you're checking all the sides it's just
like in a relationship how was your day
honey how are you doing honey can I buy
you anything else honey do you want me
just listen honey okay honey you got to
do all the sides after that you're gonna
then flip it and this is gonna take some
skill and it's gonna take some practice
now don't worry it's not a beauty
pageant
okay this egg is not getting any awards
and you're not gonna do everything
perfect use that make sure you can play
your position so after that there was
some cheese on top and because it's
flipped it might look a little it's
gonna look a little janky and that's
fine but you can put the cheese on top
you're gonna Pat it down still and that
heat is just gonna melt the cheese and
then you're just gonna have almost like
a long cheesy scrambled goodness it's
just it's amazing in a pot that's what
it really is it's amazing in a pot after
that we're then going to take our
croissants out the oven we're gonna
butter those up a little bit just like
you have to butter up your woman hey
girl I like those heels they look good
today hey girl it's like which I see
what you did with your nails go ahead
did the old lady hook you up today you
gotta butter it up a little bit then
we're gonna throw the omelet on top
there
throw some Tomatoes some avocado put the
top of your sandwich on and that's it
you built the happy house you built the
happy relationship happy life happy wife
happy Altima breakfast sandwich after
seeing these sandwiches is gonna be
crazy if destiny doesn't pick me these
are like awesome she's gonna love I need
I need a co-pilot and I can cook so you
might as well just come under your
destiny it's perfect for you is built
it's built for you right here just come
fit in they beat this Lego piece hey
guys my name is saya Ola I'm super
excited to be here today because I am
looking full look today I'm making
destiny of cornflakes french toast on a
lazy Sunday morning what I'm at home and
I'm not doing much and I want to eat
something real good french toast as
always like my go-to dish to make it's
super easy it's very simple because it
has a lot of flavor a lot of tasty but
it's something that you could do in a
snap of a finger
especially ladies at Sunday we have
nothing to do once you finish whisking
your egg mixture together you bring your
brioche bread over brioche is very
important because I think that's the
best bread for a french toast bring it
over to your egg mixture dip it and I
see on one side once that's done you
transfer it over set of cornflakes and
press it down nicely real soft thing
flip it to the opposite side press it
down real easy before you put it to the
pan though it's very important and you
put some butter in the pan you don't
want to overcook the butter I would say
medium heat a low heat is perfect
because once the butter turns to brown
that means you're burning the butter
once the butter is melted completely you
transfer your bread over to the pan you
keep an eye on it make sure you're not
overcooking your french toast so much on
one side once it's done flip it over to
the opposite side it's gonna be nice and
golden if I like cooking is the best way
to bring two people together cooking is
love when you cook from the heart it
means a lot personally I think my dish
is gonna be the winning dish it's
because I'm cooking with love cooking
from the heart
I think Destiny's gonna love this dish
because as a balance of sweetness the
crunch the flavor all combined together
it's perfect here's my favorite part
it's all about details and
the part of plate in the dish of course
step one is your syrup just a little bit
coat it nicely all over and your next
step is your berries so for me when I'm
putting on the berries it's all about
details and it's a masterpiece that's
art then after you're done placing your
berries you go with the powdered sugar
so now that I'm done I'm super excited
this dish is beautiful it looks great
and I know Destiny's gonna take this
because if she takes this takes me I'm
not worried about the other guys you
know why cuz I'm cooking with love sort
of Maddie's destiny you're gonna pick
this station
these are like fancy restaurant like
style meals I was expecting like
scrambled eggs maybe a couple pancakes
some waffles in my experience men
usually can't cook at all so I feel like
this is like a pleasant surprise I
cannot wait to try these let's go with
number one it's like cooked in something
mmm fresh raspberries this is good this
is like on a Sunday morning I would love
this all right oh nice crispy croissant
hmm the egg has a lot of flavor I love a
good breakfast sandwich I like that one
mmm oh wait wait get my hot sauce on all
right
the avocado is really smooth I love a
good like smooth avocado spread I don't
love it super chunky and the egg is
fried like perfectly I love like the
runny yolk and it's really really really
flavorful this is gonna be really hard
these are all so good like who knew we
had people here that could cook so the
first dish that I'm going to eliminate
is the sandwich it was really delicious
but it didn't really feel Sunday morning
to me so this one's got to go sorry
sandwich mean I'm the same guy my gosh I
take this personally that's not taking a
person you know thank you Andrew so good
yeah
Oh enjoy then there were two oh this is
so hard
Sunday morning you wake up it can either
be a cozy day it could be a productive
day what would I want to eat the dish
that I'm going to eliminate is the
avocado toast in it it was really good
but probably not my go-to Sunday dish hi
I made the avocado it was really good it
was delicious the egg was like perfect
thank you yes in the hot sauce was that
your idea that was my addition I was
like so good I love hot sauce I'm glad
you like this it was very nice meeting
you I'm glad I could cook for you thank
you thank you with you I am really
excited to meet whoever made this bomb
french toast what I do oh my god do you
want to eat it okay let you try it those
corn flakes this does that butter I
don't know wow
so good what we gonna do enjoy this okay
okay let's do it comment below and we
want to see the rest in a date let's go
[Music]
oh yes
[Music]